let's see if you know what this is from
do you know what this is from
Patrick I think you said whatever it is
you want to do creatively that you
should do it no matter what even if it's
for free
yeah oh yes yeah
um
well in the very beginning I was making
films and not thinking about film
festivals or I I I was I was making them
really exploring the art and and now 16
years later looking back
I think it really caused me to
build a fundamental understanding of the
moving image and and what it is to
juxtapose it and how to tell a story
with the camera
and
I didn't have all this pressure on me
when in the very beginning so like if
you really love to do something you can
figure out how to get something made you
can find friends to pull together and in
today's day and age there's so many ways
to to build stuff nowadays with the
digital technology with everything at
our fingertips that
if you really want to do it you can get
this stuff out there I mean it's crazy
to even say it right now because it's so
long and it's almost like we've heard it
so many times now you know you have
people uh people like Sean Baker who
made Tangerine yeah that's good that's
the second one yeah yeah that's good
yeah maybe maybe Tangerine with his
iPhone back then
the iPhones now are even better right
you know so everybody's got these
cameras so it's so that's really where
that comes from it's just the concept of
I I didn't think to myself oh I need to
do a Kickstarter to raise money to make
this thing just make something
and then if you do that you're going to
get people's attention and and
eventually I mean I was never even
thinking about getting film budgets and
then it just naturally built into
getting them but I think it's only
because of the drive to never stop
making
you know as you can make a short film
you can make 50 short films in this
house and every single one would look
different to a degree depending on what
the genre is how you shoot it what the
story is so
I think that at the end of the day
if you want to do something do it
and if you don't do it then it's only
it's your fault
is there one film out there that's your
film school that when you watch it it
teaches you so much whether you turn the
sound down whether you you speed it up
where like it has so many things that it
teaches you about filmmaking
inadvertently it's not actually about
yeah filmmaking
well
I do have a particular movie that caught
my fancy and caused me to re-watch it
numerous times
let's see if you know what this is from
do you know what this is from
okay so A Clockwork Orange yeah okay
yeah okay great so close
I'll fix this before I mess up the audio
oh that's nice that's a nice tattoo I
like that I I got that to remind myself
of what you're you're mentioning
actually
cloudwork orange is interesting to me
for multiple reasons and one of those
reasons is Stanley Kubrick had made 2001
A Space Odyssey went completely over
budget and wanted to show the studio you
can make an independent film so in
public orange a lot of times he's
running a camera he's doing a lot of the
editing he is putting together a lot of
the sound and as this moment where I
suddenly realized that's how I was
making films early on so I watched
cloudwork orange constantly and I was
reading this book on Stanley Kubrick and
how he puts his films together
and he talks about designing his films
like chess moves
and if you look at cloudwork Orange and
the way that he juxtaposes juxtaposes
close-ups and wide shots and the way he
lit almost everything's lit with these
natural light bulbs I mean he got these
high powered light bulbs but if you
watch it they're inside the shots all
over the place so he would try to light
the same 360. sometimes not like the
scene where they beat up the homeless
man in the beginning and and that film
is so people come into cloudwork orange
and and have such a misconception of
what it's even about because really I
think it's about the fact that it's
almost like a futuristic Coming of Age
story
it's this weird Grimm's Fairy Tale
Coming of Age story about this guy
learning who he truly is and how you
can't change who you are
but half the film he's being horrible
and corrupt and then the other half of
the film everyone that he's been
horrible to is getting the revenge on
him but a lot of times people can't make
it past the halfway point of the movie
so I always meet these people I talk to
about the movie that didn't fully see
the whole picture
with all that said another facet is
Kubrick was only filmmaker from my
understanding in the history books that
was able to pull that movie out of an
entire country because of death threats
he was having
and stuff of that sort so to me that
movie I think I I wanted to get the
tattoo to remind myself of where I
started making films and what was in my
head in the beginning of of putting
images together in sound
and so call work orange I I think would
definitely be one for lots of young
filmmakers to dive into because there's
so much there in the movements and
everything is purposeful every single
detail in all of his movies as we know
but yeah do you play chess I do yeah
yeah because I think didn't he play for
extra money
on his plain chest to pay his rent but
yeah yeah yeah
and so do you find in some ways that a
film set is like a chess game it is my
saying that I always say is I'm playing
chess not checkers
so everything I'm trying to decide what
what the next movie is I'm thinking
about the movie I'm going to do after
that and and so on and hoping that you
know because I mean you can't some
filmmakers have gone from their indie
film straight up to the 100 million
dollar budget and then that movie failed
and then they lost their career
so I feel like there is kind of you
really you know building up and what
you're doing but then also going back to
Onset if there's an issue
not only should you be ahead of it and
the concept of as a director dealing
with it and putting the issue to rest
but at the same time it's like how you
deal with somebody's mentality is how
they're going to react for instance I
was making a feature film my second one
in Cincinnati Ohio it was one of my
final projects before I came out west
and I went outside for a quick phone
call when I came back inside everybody
was shocked and a Gentleman had walked
over and just hit the detach button on
my tripod so the camera fell and broke
the lens
I was so in shock at the time because
everybody's reacting that I'm thinking
in my head that I have to be joking you
know I it's not really broken and the
next day we're gonna film this scene in
a tent and the wide-angle lens had just
gotten broken
now my friend thought he said I thought
you were gonna attack this guy
I I saw it broken in his hands and I
took a deep breath and I calmed myself
and I asked him to step outside and we
had a conversation I told him don't
worry about it he almost started crying
I said it's okay accidents happen and
little did I realize his mother was a
little bit wealthier and was able to
purchase us the exact same lens the very
next day that I had bought that lens
used and then she brought she came to
set and brought us a brand new version
of the lens
and if I would have reacted angry he
would have ran away embarrassed
and I you know and so instead I I tried
to be kind and compassionate towards the
situation
and so I think there's you know the
lesson there is always stay calm you
know no matter what's taking place sure
you said something
how you've seen
an indie filmmaker make a low budget
film and then jump to a studio movie and
it possibly could ruin that person's
career do you think it's always about
that the story or the product was bad or
that sometimes no people don't want to
see somebody make such an easy leap
could happen with companies too like oh
this is getting too big we can't have
this
this person shouldn't have gotten that
chance I don't know yeah I'm just
wondering oh no that's interesting
that's interesting well
one particular situation is an indie
filmmaker went to make a big franchise
film and another franchise film came out
at the same time and so one of them
tanked at the box office and so it was I
mean in the movies a good movie
um and then I think that I don't know
how the studio system works in that
respect like I don't know how they view
those numbers or have conversations
amongst themselves but I can imagine you
have to put the blame on somebody for
why the thing didn't do well and then
who do you point out is the novice
director coming off of uh 250 000 movie
so I I I and I I believe when I was
reading this my first inclination was
you should make four or five movies
before you make that hundred million
dollar
because Ron Howard's film The Star Wars
one he made I don't think it grossed as
much money as the other Star Wars
pictures did but he's Ron Howard
so I mean I think if you're comfortable
in that setting then it's harder to be
the reason perhaps but
yeah so I don't know I mean just what
I've seen in studio filmmaking I feel
like you really have to go into that
with the concept of playing chess and
not checkers
because you really have to make those
decisions on like how you're going to
push your career because your film's got
to make money if they're not making
money then you're not making movies
sure but that you know that's great that
you brought up you know Ron Howard and
he's Ron Howard it's different if you
look you know you were in San Francisco
for a while so these quote unquote I
hate to use this term but Tech
disruptors I know it's cliche but
um some some may have had an idea or a
company that was actually brilliant but
maybe it did it disrupted the status quo
too much and the powers that be didn't
want that so if the Newbie comes and
does something whether it's good or not
yeah you Rose too fast yeah this isn't
gonna work but if you're an established
name
I think A lot's about the change though
too with the concept of just so many
Indie investors
there's so much money there and that now
there's so many streaming services I
think even AMC is more accessible to try
to distribute your movie theatrically
yourself hence all these Distributors
popping up out of nowhere or there's
tons and tons of film Distributing
distribution companies
so I really think at the end of the day
where the studio system is planted
themselves with doing these hundred
million dollar movies and they've
basically removed the 20 30 million
dollar dramas and stuff that they were
making forever
I feel like inevitably the Indie cinema
world is going to overtake most of what
that is or maybe that's going to
compartmentalize a bid or maybe it's
always going to be there I mean really
at the end of the day
I think there's a lot of money there to
make all kinds of films so
you know whether or not it's it's it's
the studio system or something Indie I
think that maybe they'll they'll exist
but I guess really what I'm getting at
is it's a time where you can really do
whatever you want and get things out
there I mean there's so many indie films
that end up in Mass releases in theaters
that are made with no one's permission
maybe that's where it goes to
feeling like you have to ask someone's
permission or need to get the money to
to do this thing or
why yeah